stop me if you've heard this one before
a young man was driving home from work
late one rainy night when he spotted a
woman in a white dress and a red sweater
walking along the shoulder of the road
concerned for her safety he slowed down
and rolled down the window so he could
talk to her
when he asked where she was going she
said she was walking to her parents
house
the man pulled over and offered her a
ride that she accepted
the woman gave him the address of her
home hopped in the back seat
and the man drove off she sensed that
she must have been cold from walking in
the rain
so he cranked up the car's heater to
help her dry off
soon she removed her heavy red sweater
and placed it on the seat next to her
the man tried to make friendly
conversation
asking if the woman had a job what she
was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet
staring out the window until they drove
past
an old graveyard the woman began
pounding on the glass of the car as if
she desperately wanted something
unsure of what to do the man pulled over
but before he could ask her what was
happening she had gotten out of the car
he exited the car to try and find her
but the woman was nowhere
to be seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away
he went on his way and didn't think of
it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car
he decided to go to the house she had
originally given him the address for and
give it back to her
he found the home without any trouble
but when he knocked on the door
the old woman who answered it was
confused by his story
she told them that her daughter couldn't
have possibly left her sweater in his
car
because she died in a car accident 30
years ago
the vanishing hitchhiker is a classic
ghost story with the details varying
from place to place
and storyteller to storyteller in
chicago she goes by resurrection mary
named after the graveyard she asks for
rides to in okinawa japan she's known as
the night walker of nago
and she only appears to taxi drivers in
kent england
she's suzanne a bride killed in a car
wreck on the way to her bachelorette
party
in north carolina her name is lydia and
in hawaii she's believed to be the
goddess pele
in human form but as far as our friends
at the scp foundation are concerned
the vanishing hitchhiker's name is mary
talish
also known as scp-1337
on the 19th of may 1952 college
sophomore mary talish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of
muncie indiana
when police found her body two weeks
later her eyes and heart had been torn
from her body in a ritualistic fashion
and she had scrapes and bruises that
suggested she had been beaten before her
murder
her killers were never caught and her
body was returned to her family for
burial
intolerance and starting on the 19th
of june that same year someone matching
mary's description
a caucasian woman with blonde hair
standing 150 centimeters tall and
wearing a red sweater
was spotted trying to flag down passing
vehicles along mayflower road
since then every month on the 19th mary
has been sighted along that stretch of
road
and every month the same scenario plays
out
mary gives anyone who picks her up
directions to her parents house
then on the way she instructs the driver
to stop at the graveyard where she was
buried
she vanishes from the car leaving her
sweater the driver of the car tries to
return the sweater to her parents house
only to be told that mary tallish was
dead when the scp foundation was made
aware of mary talish's pattern of
haunting in the late 50s
they set up a system where agents would
patrol mayflower road at hourly
intervals with the intention of picking
mary up
agents were sent on their own in
non-foundation cars
and instructed to stick to the accepted
script of the vanishing hitchhiker
legend
without attempting to engage mary in
further conversation
mary's parents were also given e-class
agent status to keep them from speaking
about the haunting
and told that the foundation was working
on a way to set the spirit to rest
early attempts to study the apparition
were inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her
or trigger her manifestation outside of
the 19th of every month
and attempts to analyze her sweater were
fruitless since if the sweater wasn't
returned to the talish family home
it would simply vanish from containment
at or around sunset
on the next 19th for 20 years
scp-1337 events continued to happen as
normal
d-class personnel under the instruction
of the foundation would pick mary up
drive her past the cemetery and return
her sweater to her parents
it was business as usual and in fact it
was one of the more sedate reoccurring
apparitions the foundation had to deal
with
but as you might have guessed that piece
wouldn't last
forever enter dr lawson who in 1972 was
placed in charge of all resources
regarding
scp-1337 dr lawson was getting sick of
all this phantom hitchhiker business
and while most of the foundation was
happy to keep this routine going
lawson thought the continual picking up
and dropping off of mary talish and her
red sweater was a waste of the
foundation's valuable time
after all it was the early 70s the price
of oil was at an all-time high
so the expense of sending car after car
up and down the same road for a solid
day once a month just to pick up a ghost
was more trouble than it was worth so
lawson started developing a plan
one that he didn't go through the proper
foundation channels to approve
he reasoned that the reason mary's ghost
kept coming back was because she wanted
something since always asked for a ride
home then it must mean she wanted to
return back to her parents
so logic followed that if she had
nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
june
1973 lawson went ahead with his plan
without his superior's knowledge
and ordered the execution of mary
talash's parents
as well as the immediate demolition of
their family home
according to his journals lawson had
hoped that his attempt at
decommissioning 1337 would significantly
cut the foundation's gas bills
freeing up valuable funds at which point
he'd surely be promoted in recognition
of his brilliance
but that wasn't what happened lawson was
demoted from team leader to junior staff
and only kept on 1337 detail out of the
belief that
without a family to return to lawson
would become the new focal point of the
haunting should mary tallish ever return
though lawson's actions weren't at all
above board even by scp foundation
standards
they did seem to have worked the 19th of
june came and went without a single
merry sighting
and she wasn't seen the next month
either a full year went by without any
sign of the mayflower road apparition
satisfied with this turn of events the
foundation made the decision to
officially reclassify
scp-1337 from safe to
safe decommissioned and the gas money
that was budgeted for the mayflower road
patrol was redirected to the scp-682
tank acid fund but even though
everything seemed to have been sorted
out
boston wasn't entirely satisfied and not
just because of his demotion
whether it was intuition or merely
guilt-induced paranoia is unclear
but he suspected that mary was still out
there somewhere
at first he thought that she might show
up on the anniversary of her parents
deaths
but then that date came and went as did
eight more anniversaries
after it finally on the 19th of june
1983
lawson decided he had to see for himself
fitted with recording equipment
he drove alone in a non-foundation
standard car
down that lonely stretch of road where
so many before him had stopped to pick
up that mysterious blonde woman with the
red sweater
he had to prove to himself that she
wouldn't show up that he had really
and truly gotten rid of her for good it
was about five o'clock in the evening
when he reached mayflower road
at first he didn't experience anything
strange he scanned the roadside
looking for the phantom hitchhiker
walking along it but there was
nobody there dr lawson breathed a sigh
of relief
he may have orchestrated the deaths of
two innocent people
but at least it hadn't been for nothing
he turned on the recorder he brought
with him and logged that nothing had
happened
scp-1337 had been permanently
neutralized as he approached the
t-intersection and prepared to turn onto
marsh avenue
he looked up to adjust his rear-view
mirror to his horror
he found that he wasn't alone in the car
someone was in the seat behind him
someone with blonde hair and a red
sweater
his last transmission consisted only of
wait who the hell are you
before the recording abruptly stopped
lawson's car was found soon after by
foundation agents
lawson was dead in the front seat
bruised and bloody
with his eyes and heart ripped out in a
ritualistic fashion
just the way mary tallish had been found
all the way back
in 1952 it turns out that mary hadn't
been neutralized after all
she'd just been waiting for a chance to
get revenge
on the man who killed her family and
mary didn't stop with dr lawson
no longer does she appear walking along
the road waiting for someone to offer
her a ride before disappearing without
incident
now should someone pass by without
offering a ride
she will appear in their back seat
before reenacting the method of her own
death upon the driver
and her physical appearance has changed
too whereas before she looked like the
image of a pretty young woman before her
tragedy
now recordings show that she appears
with the wounds of her death present
her eyes gouged out in their sockets and
a massive hole in her chest
where her heart should be the same
wounds
she inflicts on her victims the scp
foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road
but that has only resulted in mary
manifesting at other locations in
and around meensy foundation documents
reveal that any back road in the city
can potentially serve as host to a 1337
event
and all attempts to contain the
apparition have failed
the only way someone who has seen mary
can avoid her wrath
is by stopping to pick her up at which
point she will dematerialize
before reappearing on another road
mobile task forces have been
unsuccessful
as mary only appears to those driving
alone and all agents who have been sent
on solo missions to apprehend her have
resulted in the death of the agent
as cp 1337 was reinstated
this time as euclid class currently the
foundation's method of managing
scp-1337 is to dispatch a security team
on the 19th of every month
to monitor all the places where a
potential sighting could take place
as soon as signs of a manifestation are
identified a remotely controlled vehicle
containing a single d-class is driven to
the location
once mary appears in the car the car is
piloted to the empty lot where her home
used to stand
and the remains of the d-class are then
disposed of
like a lot of the stories that could
pass down as urban legends
the story of scp-1337 has a lesson that
can be taken away from it
this scp started off as an ordinary
local haunting
no more deadly than lydia suzanne
resurrection mary
or any of the countless other local
versions of the vanishing hitchhiker
story
but thanks to one rogue foundation
doctor and his desire to rush what he
thought would be
an efficient solution the spirit not
only became harder to control
but also much more violent and
bloodthirsty
than anyone was prepared to deal with so
if there's anything we can learn here
it's that no matter if you're a student
an office worker
or a researcher with the scp foundation
think twice about cutting corners it
might save you a little bit of time and
money in the short term
but in the long term the results could
be
fatal now go check out scp-087 the
stairwell
and scp-035 the possessive mask
for more explanations of the creepiest
scp
tales